you
this is the new lavarro from
opel/vauxhall with sales of over 600,000
units the Lavar owes captured ten
percent of the light commercial vehicle
market in Europe now with the second
generation built in close cooperation
with Renault and Nissan opal is after
even more the market share of this
growing segment the car makers are
focusing on keeping the cost for the
customer down is because that time oppo
stefan logic says for one they've
extended the time between inspections
from once every year and 20,000
kilometers to every two years and 40,000
kilometers that considerably reduces
operating costs more savings come from
the choice of engine for the new vivaro
a 1.6 litre twin-turbo this powertrain
has made a lot of progress in terms of
fuel efficiency compared with the
previous vivaro it consumes about one
and a half liters less fuel per hundred
kilometers una cometa i squashed in
pittsylvania types of football he's on
schematic cartas de Montes current is
quite impressed with a vivaro swin turbo
engine he says it's nippy free revving
and still thrifty
the one point six liters put out 88
kilowatts of power and pushes the van up
to a top speed of 171 km/h fuel
consumption is rated at a decent 5.9
litres per 100 kilometers our test model
featured start/stop technology to recoup
braking energy and save even more opel
made sure the new vivaro actually looks
like a noble with the makes own design
language the flowing blade side feature
and the signature wing design for the
daytime running lights the new bigger
edition also offers more space into the
head klappa Mata says behind the rear
doors is the nuvo Varro's 2.5 3-meter
cargo space 10 centimeters longer than
before enough space for say a kitchen
range cooking sila mmm Oh daba or a
grand piano even if mutters can't play
very well oda poor to get practical
again three year old pallets placed end
to end and with that flap opened up the
driver can slide the long objects like
roof beams and pipes under the passenger
seat all the way into the foot well
depending on the wheelbase the new
vivaro can transport loads up to three
and three-quarter metres long the
interior hints at the downside of a
three-way joint venture with the
blower's rimmed in piano black
the instruments a navigation system and
silver and the stick shift in chrome a
coherent design would have served better
on the upside the cabinet's plenty of
storage space
look I'm parked Montes would like to
point out another feature designed to
make the drivers life easier he has to
pull over first hits the center front
seat that he can easily fold down and
take the back off to use as a clipboard
easy time the alcohols name on Tatia so
I'm Clampett a crisp transmission and
responsive steering also add to the plus
side especially on a van we're handling
like this is unexpected montes realizes
this is no luxury car it's a tradesman's
van and what's important to trades
people is the cargo space in the new
edition it's 10 centimetres longer and
quite a bit more practical the good
ideas that went into the cabin and the
longer payload area are definite pluses
the new lavarro can tally up against its
competitors only thing kadar Khan de
bávaro gig ensign de mikvah vava poems
the vivaro rose competitors in Germany
are the VW t5 and the Ford Transit the
mercedes vito and suit wins jumpy and
germany the new bavaro starts at just
over twenty eight thousand euros a
competitive price for a competitive and
but it's the fuel efficiency that just
might tip the scale it will also be
available as a combi van with seating
for nine for a price of just over thirty
thousand euros
by Mia missing this Mindy our tester
writer is a motorcycle enthusiast and a
one liter engine is as low as he'll go
he likes to ride in both the city and
the countryside he's never driven an
electric scooter and is a bit reluctant
to compare having always looked down on
things like this but now he's curious to
see if he can really keep up with his
bike MIT meinem Autobots that'll be
tight and cut my song thought earth
ottoman trainer says starting up takes a
little time but then you press the
button and off you go the sea evolution
is the first electric scooter from BMW
and despite running on batteries it's
snow weakling we can give it to a biker
like Reiner in good conscience the e
scooter can zip from 0 to 50 km/h in 2.7
seconds and from 0 to 100 and 6.2 the
Kaiba diesel BMW Stefan schaller says
the bike fills a new niche the company
doesn't expect it to be a volume seller
right away but it's an innovative way to
meet the needs of certain customers to
make the vision of a zero-emission
scooter a reality a lot of technology
had to fit into a small space all the
electrical parts are contained in this
tough metal box that also serves as the
scooters frame
benzene is photo/stephan schaller says
that writers won't notice any difference
in normal city traffic except for the
lack of noise and emissions thanks to
the battery box the center of gravity is
very low that results in excellent road
handling making it very maneuverable the
low battery box makes these improvements
possible these are all sinless father at
Don's place in futsal doesn't scooters
are very popular in Barcelona the police
also use them they quickly noticed our
new electric scooter and wanted to find
out more about it from Reiner he told
them for example that the scooter has an
electronic speed limiter that only kicks
in at 120 km/h the see evolution has no
trouble zooming along Barcelona streets
and that's even though it has a rated
output of just 11 kilowatts due to its
high torque of 72 Newton meters the
electric scooter leaves most of its
gasoline-powered brethren far behind at
the traffic light
the batteries used the same technology
that BMW employees in its small electric
car the i3 Griffin the C evolution BMW
uses three high-voltage lithium-ion
modules also found in the i3 these have
been configured so that they fit in the
battery housing which also acts as a
structural chassis element that can
carry the weight of the scooter they owe
us Vaman consultants traiga tint Oh mrs.
fat psychic closet suit on the C
evolution striking lime green color
makes it stand out the scooter weighs
around two hundred sixty five kilograms
and features a reversing aid that makes
it easy to maneuver the C evolution is
BMWs first electric maxi scooter a full
charge takes around for hours and allows
for a range of around 100 kilometers
becoming the man from BMW says the
overall market for motorcycles has been
contracting slightly for the last six
years so the company must keep dreaming
of things to attract new clients with
the sea evolution they feel they'll be
able to attract not only tradition
motorbike riders but also customers who
currently don't use motorcycles or other
gas-powered vehicles but who like the
fact that it has zero emissions he's
certain the East scooter will appeal to
car drivers and new customers who've
never had anything to do with motorbikes
golden denise smith moto episode 2 total
nub so what's our testers verdict could
the sea evolution convince Reiner the
motorcycle rider faint mandela he says
he can tell from the smile on his face
that the scooter is pretty good Reiner
doesn't want to exaggerate but says he
was always the first to pull away at
every traffic light the scooter
accelerates well and impressed him in
the city Reiner says his bike still
faster but not at traffic lights he
feels the scooters ideal for the city
and is great on curves just like a
motorbike the only thing he doesn't like
is the 15,000 euro price tag and that
the scooter must be recharged after 100
kilometers though you can charge it
overnight ah that's coming to buy knock
knock he says he'd by the sea evolution
for the city and use his motorbike the
rest of the time unfazed by de moto
the first Toyota AYGO went on the market
in 2005 spent a great success but to
keep up with the ever tougher
competition Toyota went back to the
drawing board the design of the new I go
stands out and it offers many
customization options of fifty one
kilowatt 1-liter 3-cylinder power is the
I go and consumes 4.1 liters of fuel per
100 kilometers VW will roll out the
off-road beetle dune in early 2016
unfortunately to get it into production
quickly VW dropped many of the good
ideas from the design study production
models won't include the ski rack that
goes over the rear window for example at
least there's a two-color spoiler and
Beatle fans looking forward to all wheel
drive will also be disappointed
around 800 asphalt Cowboys follow the
call of the first Mustang Club of
Germany and brought their automotive
wild horses to the 33rd international
Mustang meeting in Cologne hear the
distinctive burbling sound of v8 engines
is heard everywhere as fans come to mark
the 50th anniversary of Ford's pony car
visitors can admire the Mustangs of
today and yesteryear spins I'd form says
he's been chairman of the first Mustang
Club of Germany for some 25 years
originally the club was dedicated to
first generation Mustangs built between
1964 1973 but now it organizes the
meeting for Mustangs of all vintages
form says they never wanted to be just a
small group of first generation fans so
they've been able to present 50 years of
Mustangs here in Cologne on 50 alamos
young men defect positive car meets like
this always draw unusual cars and their
owners like this Mustang decked out in
the colors of the Chicago Bears football
team and its owner who's painted his
nails to match
this Highway Patrol show car ensures law
and order prevail at the meet and this
Mustang from Holland is a replica of a
race car with an interesting history now
this is actually it's a replica of a
race car that was owned by Tim Allen the
actor from home improvement a TV series
in the mid 90s he actually financed the
racing team of steve saleen and because
he put so much money in they offered him
a racing seat on the team so actually
the three cars that they raised in the
SSC a pro series one of them was
occasionally driven by Tim Allen himself
and this car is actually a replica of
the car how his car used to look back in
the 90s the mere sight of a dragster
like this is enough to set a Mustang
fans heart racing but it wasn't love at
first sight for all the owners here bob
has never imagined he'd fall for this
green machine
pinned on the elbow voguish study says
he stumbled across his green frog and
got in started it up and then the fever
hit him point of all this fever is Donna
if that Mustang fever ever turns into a
raging fire this car could help him cool
down movie buffs will recognize this
replica of Eleanor the 1967 fastback
Mustang Nicolas Cage steals and gone in
60 seconds Ford marked the Mustangs 50th
anniversary by showing off its 2015
edition of the car for the first time in
Europe at the meeting in Cologne
everyone wanted to get a shot of the new
model
you have to dig in Fords York buyer says
as executive director for global
programs he had a chance to collaborate
on the new Mustang in the US he says
they had very high aims the vehicle had
to drive well look smart and thrilled
people but ford also wanted the Mustang
to remain an affordable sports car an
English a fox fought back black Ford
hasn't set a price for the new Mustang
in Europe but it's known it will offer a
choice of two engines there's the 2.3
liter four-cylinder EcoBoost which in
spite of its 227 kilowatts is
fuel-efficient those wanting a classic
American motor can opt for the five
liter v8 which generates 313 kilowatts
but fans will have to wait a bit longer
before it hits the streets